学ぶ美味しそうでそっち
今日は5月の26日の日曜日なんですけども今日はですねあのガンホーさんのイベント
ガーンフェスというイベントが幕張メッセで行われております僕はですねちょして
いただいているんですけどもどうなるミッションが多分を与えられるんですよ
それも相当なその密書をちょっと受けるべく今から東京じゃない買おうと思います
いい
ています
結構ねぇ find 結構緊張しておりますこういうん
ああああああん
wh
me
はいというわけで元日の改造につきました実はですね僕のこの
指に何個の宝石だこれが楽しく8000万ダウンロード突破って聞いたことがあるんで
少なくとも発生マン欠ける中
が強く個発注9個の宝石が僕のこの指にかかっていますランキング男女で挑戦していい
スコアが出バカっていくんですけど頑張ったイベントが終わるまで僕が7%より上の
ランキングに入るとパズドラやってる方全員に
ブーバーインチ4鉢をピコってすごい活気カーサーになると思います
ん
台座のいいすごい
慶應グッズにまたすぐ異形の金田の宝石動くという事だけ覚えてるけどやっていき
ましょうね
ni
影響のないで僕で心強いなくなっているねぇ
でございないんだよ
rar
皆さんいらっしゃいません
もっとやっておけば良かったよ
none
9分
ええええええ
ううううう普通
car
goo
none
car
me
[音楽]
ウーマンじゃないんだ
me
2000ぐらいでの
これはたぶん
当選 p 度を上げていくだけです頑張ります
[音楽]
なんてピンパーマできましたん
ana
me
ああああっおっけどっこれも大丈夫です
大丈夫大丈夫ですよねさすがにもう売って
2.9ばです
こいつはどう day by gd
台風ディズニー天気ば入ったんですけど
現像にで旧パンのだけででガーディスが終われば出るならカー店舗 no 1に入っ
てると魔法的不利に配布でございます
もうやっていくためさんが大丈夫機でもうエンディングまで皆様にしてみます
[音楽]
始め佐藤がバンクが出て開けませんから始め瀬戸
うん
ni
うんもう1さん
結構やったんですけど前
みんな多分難いですよね
こちらですねイングランドのターン
変数開催記念ダイバーがした海外挑戦を始め者直していない
はい今日一日八番街を抜かない空
ブーバーし
me
はじめして君ととは非常に重たいね
一応対するなんだとかそしてこの暫定移駐
ファイター tj ありますのであって
オーナー稲川をはじめしたとも
杏ねキレイ
確認したいですはい思いますそう
調布に探してもらっていいですよね画面準備はよろしいですよ入ったわけです
お願いします
はぁさあ ni
new サドン教えていただきましょうかはいはいそれはうーん
さあいきましょう
現在地をぜねー
goo ん
ブーフを
ああああああ
me
[音楽]
あっはぁ
re 俺はあああああ
ああああああああ
俺は知らせ魔法石も運営
ee 1 oo
ああああああ